think you know everything there is to
know about the Big Bang Theory hi hi hi
hi here's a pop quiz which two
characters were played by the same actor
Five Seasons apart yes while plenty of
actors dreamed of guest starring on this
beloved sitcom one lucky performer got
to do it twice with two different
characters get ready to say how did I
not notice that as major fans of the
Beloved sitcom we all know that the Big
Bang Theory was successful enough to run
for a whopping 12 seasons and fans got
to see plenty of different characters
Grace the screen over the course of that
long run do you like a tissue of course
not every character had a lot of screen
time and not every guest star had a
recurring role like Christine baransky
or Stephen Hawking as a result of this
pattern even the biggest Big Bang Theory
fans may have forgotten a few of the
characters and guest stars who they saw
along the way it seems that the creators
and casting Department Behind The Big
Bang Theory must have been counting on
this when they cast actor Molly Morgan
in two different episodes as two
entirely different characters one of the
only reasons that the show was able to
get away with this interesting and
highly unusual casting Choice was
because the first episode Morgan
appeared in was in season three while
the second wasn't until much later in
season 8. six years gave us enough time
to forget Morgan's face before her
second character showed up so who were
Molly Morgan's characters on The Big
Bang Theory you may be asking well her
first appearance was in 2009 on season 3
episode 3 The gothowitz deviation what
are you gonna get Howard in this episode
she plays a goth woman named Bethany and
Howard manages to pick her up sure the
relationship between the two doesn't
exactly last so Bethany never appears on
another episode but while some guest
stars would likely be hoping for their
character to return for more episodes
and may have lamented their characters
short Arc this wasn't necessary Siri for
Molly Morgan to continue her Big Bang
Theory career she managed to make an
entirely different appearance do you
remember the escape room host from
season 8. you have to look for the clues
hidden around the room yeah there was a
catastrophic accident that was Molly
Morgan too in season 8 episode 16 the
intimacy acceleration the group goes to
an escape room and none other than Molly
Morgan is the host her character is
listed as Hostess so we can only assume
that she isn't supposed to be Bethany
making a surprising coincidental return
but hey Howard isn't there so maybe they
all simply don't recognize each other
it's very possible if you happen to be
thinking that you actually do recognize
Molly Morgan's face from somewhere else
well it's probably because you do she's
guest starred on quite a few other
Series in fact her first appearance on
our TV screens was actually way back in
1985 on the Twilight Zone ew daddy you
didn't shave this morning since then
she's appeared on many other series like
Full House weeds baskets Dexter law
order SV you phones and Two and a Half
Men just to name a few so it's clear
that Molly Morgan is no stranger to
appearing on television series as a
guest star but believe it or not she's
actually no stranger to playing two
different characters as a guest star on
the same series either being cast as
double roles on The Big Bang Theory
actually wasn't the first time she
managed to accomplish this unusual
acting feat way back in 1994 Morgan
appeared on Boy Meets World in two
different episodes as you guessed it two
completely different characters she
appeared in season 2 episode 2 pairing
off as Jacqueline and then later that
same season in episode 11 the beard as
Stacy so Molly Morgan may have been the
only guest star to appear as multiple
different characters but she was far
from the only guest star over the course
of 12 Seasons the sitcom hosted over 60
celebrity guest stars as well as plenty
of others there were guest stars who
actually played themselves like Neil
deGrasse Tyson and Stephen Hawking as
well as stars who were friends of the
show's main cast like Laurie Metcalfe
who played Mary Cooper and Sarah Gilbert
who played Leslie Winkle both of whom
famously acted with the series star
Johnny Galecki in the Beloved sitcom
Roseanne there were so many other guest
stars from acting greats like Kathy
Bates as Mrs Fowler Sean Aston as Dr
Craig Pemberton Judy Greer as Dr
Elizabeth Plimpton Octavia Spencer as
Octavia James Earl Jones as himself and
Christopher Lloyd as Theodore two
beloved figures like legendary comic
book writer Stan Lee as himself history
making astronaut Buzz Aldrin as himself
Elon Musk as himself and Steve Wozniak
as no surprise himself it's clear that
the Big Bang Theory creators were big
fans of featuring well-known figures
playing brand new characters and among
the series beloved main group these new
faces were always more than welcome wow
is anyone else just about ready for a
re-watch of The Big Bang Theory right
about now or is it just us we're really
ready to test the theory that that may
be Bethany in both episodes Five Seasons
apart so be honest did you catch that
Molly Morgan played both characters we
have a feeling even some super fans
missed that one if you love videos like
this one like And subscribe to the
things for more